what's up fool
welcome to the were so full podcast with
Rodrigo tourists German and over there
sporting her burgundy suit looking like
Housewives of New Jersey yeah she tracks
it we're in the track suit she's to be
married to one of the Gambino's she took
over when the other woman got locked up
it was funny I was seeing the little
story about the Gambino's what happened
well the other side of Carlo Gambino
that's where the white Castellano got
made because that's his mom's side of
the family
I don't know that can't be Carlo Gambino
the original he kept it all family huh
yeah like the people that were like
captains were all part of the family huh
yeah that's why when the homeboy did
what he did John Gotti he was from the
street like Doug to the core he took
that power dog but so Carlo Gambino yeah
he but he like he wasn't loud I've never
done any recordings never on the phone
none of that stuff killing people with a
blink of an eye yeah smoothly it wasn't
even a tall little guy big old beak
calling shots yeah man it can happen you
know how he came up how awful um Carlo
Gambino came up I think it during World
War two or World War one could he came
he was oh he came from Sicily right he
was like and they were giving out um I
think I'm during the Depression they
were giving up my um food vouchers
uh-huh right and I forgot a whole a
bunch of food bouncers and there was
standing room dude like a lot of food
vouchers 300 pressing yeah that's where
I got a bulk of the money a boca out of
money or that he was making Gaeng of
money
cuz he's originally one of the original
five families yeah so he save up that
money you know cuz he was like oh he
started small bro like he was he came up
with Lucky Luciano right and the five
the original five family but he was
looking like a smaller dude like he was
like an underling underling but he was
there bro he was there gonna mix in the
mix so now he came up and later I when
he said when I'm that dried up on the
ball state actor with a prohibition
Genet the other prohibition efforts are
making money and you like how these two
what the way they made money with them
they will transfer against um your
bootlegging and like smuggling alcohol
right but they will I put it in again
boxes with salt then the salt will come
out and then above the box you will just
pop up and then we look for them
so that's how they would smuggle that
yeah trucks or what no litter in the
ocean let the term on the ocean for took
like off a boat because sometimes they
were like take boards or they'll take
drugs to drag racing got started brought
because of prohibition right well
because Hillbillies bro these two [ __ ]
take all that moonshine up north
remember that a movie with Richard Pryor
greased lightning I never remember Pam
Grier was in it with him but he was like
back in the day he was a smuggling
moonshine that's we became a race car
driver fool all the little hick areas
that's why I'm and I'm loose to Hazzard
Uncle Jesse you never saw him anywhere
brother I fooled on house arrest for
moonshining are you serious yeah we look
at the Wikipedia the whole thing was
them running because they were
moonshiners and that's why they weren't
allowed to cross the state line and all
that's really that Daisy Duke over here
and we don't like hick we prefer the
term hillbilly thank you Bill Hicks a
rednecks
I think redneck is the preferred but
Boss Hogg he was a real boss man like
the original like his character must
have been based off some some other
movie like that
what unbag and Boss Hogg he was also a
bootlegger I think yeah he became legit
like a politician yeah Uncle Jesse got
locked up and he didn't he didn't sing
bro but they told him that he could be
they're gonna go to jail but he can't
start a bootlegging again and so I think
the The Dukes the his kids actually
bootleg yeah we're actually running
alcohol and they're not supposed to
either they're not supposed to leave
that area that
every little County they get chased and
again like you know becoming good
drivers of being fast and it's in the
that's a tree trip like you watch it and
watch you the kid like you don't know
the Confederate flag before the
Confederate soldiers I thought for the
their car for the generally I just would
you have a shirt whether generally I had
the card but I used to like to see those
fools jump and if stop halfway together
guitar be late
now how them dukes funny I saw some
article on Tom Wopat who played Luke
Duke and recently and I guess he was
accused of some sort of like
inappropriate sexual behavior with
somebody this was before all the
celebrity things started coming out and
somebody had that had had that headline
now how these Dukes Duke boys gonna get
out of this dude alright to watch Dukes
of Hazzard dude every Friday I had old
my routine eight o'clock
Wonder Woman manic manic lock Dukes of
Hazzard and they wonder what I got
canceled I mean it was not an eight
o'clock Incredible Hulk
hey man o'clock Dukes of Hazzard answer
that we either Dallas or dynasty but I
was gone but then Wonder Woman I thought
that was ABC or I think credible
Incredible Hulk was not on CBS I think
Incredible Hulk was NBC don't switch
channels it yeah maybe
did that I would look go with the Geo
channel remember exactly how these come
up at night and I forgot that I still
watch CBS
cuz I that channel may work him out good
roll oh my god yeah man oh those my
shows man Dukes of Hazzard and then um
they changed I guess I don't even know
you know you're a kid you don't
understand what's going on man like you
like you to achieve your walk
why are Bo and Luke's brothers why
they're not here with a [ __ ] why the
[ __ ] cousins here yeah I don't know
why that might have been contract
negotiation work or something I dreams
yeah that was like toward the end
and Bo no Bo and Luke Aaron you know a
so bro you how you were you I don't even
know who even is this
I loved eNOS he was my favorite nice one
he was like the nice cop he who the love
with Daisy and they they used to use her
sexy body to trick him her pantyhose
under her shorts I never know that they
well he's a tad yeah although Three's
Company women when they were short said
pantyhose to it always bothered me gusta
hazard posed a row with um with Bo and
Luke and Daisy do right there I just
Terra Daisy Duke then I got older and
everyone liked Matthew that bulges with
a cup there's to be solo posters of
Daisy yeah yeah man these photo garage
there's of all those cheeks I'm gonna
start like it went women subconsciously
bro sorry I would buy a woman then I was
influenced bro Lindo Wagner Lindsay
Wagner bro coy and Vance we where the
other were the other cousins and they
were chase - yeah but dude there was a
the Doozer begin chase but then they'll
be like this black car brought a Dean he
was on two to seven he was a sheriff of
Chickasaw County was your bro he was
like he was not bad he was all good like
he would arrest Boss Hogg's yeah he was
like Jackie Gleason's sheriff in
Cannonball Run movie I'm sorry smoking
in the band he's a good corrected I'm
sorry what or - I was cook talking about
Cannonball Run with Isaac this morning
about racing huh Buford getting away
from the cops Captain America whoa you
know like you're like being your hotel
room and then you're like you just leave
the TV on you start watching you start
changing or you're about to take a nap
so you start watching whatever is on TV
oh well watching standing tall with that
with the [ __ ] Rock
walking tall walking the talk in Johnny
Knoxville yeah my horrible you could
they could they could have done it
without Johnny Ozzy or they could you
put anybody that they're gonna put David
Spade in that room he appeared for like
an hour in the movie where'd he go
what do you beat up all those people in
the casino [ __ ] there were the drug
dealer dude yeah that dude that was born
to be played dick Rowland a little evil
guy a little blonde why here yeah yeah
he was Lex Luthor and and the Superman
show yeah what show was that although
small wheel that's it by the way um Bo
within [ __ ] Mouse mobile he played up
Clark as dad yeah it's what happened in
walking taller you know fool first of
all man
wow man just put it shoot there for a
reason I was in attack of one at a time
can we all rusty foo that's the
parliament movie Brotherhood everybody
start [ __ ] Lance cake everybody
rushes him one at a time
be real bro rush him all at once like a
Steven Seagal man [ __ ] your scene the
first first movie was badass above the
law above the law dog that's that's
right the the cousins Vance and coy on
Dukes of Hazzard replaced them during
contract negotiations but they were so
unliked
so unpopular fans they were written out
after 19 episodes about that man in 2013
both the original boy loose wear
Labrador came back look at his [ __ ]
cancel the show like he they basically
pull a Charlie Sheen without talking
[ __ ] what the cardigan
the names Vance the chorus and coy [ __ ]
bass employ and though he's that I think
they brought in their sister to
supposedly they lived on the farm before
Bo and Luke came in and then they left
they came back that's the back story and
they tried to make them like bad boys
worse like somebody said they were
younger more
better-looking yeah they were blonde and
brunette and nobody's know well they are
now go listening [ __ ] you guys they were
there always like only in like in soap
operas what they introduced like this
that someone's garden like in the role
of Lisa as far as that it'll be taken
over by Antoinette oh yeah I hated
hearing that because sometimes your
favorite actress like sometimes yeah
like sometimes your favorite character
would who was a regular was sick or
something during during filming or
taping so they would put somebody in and
they would announce it and I'd get so
mad he heard that and Kendall like
Kendall okay Kendall on All My Children
she was played by Bucky the Vampire
Slayer this boy is Buzzard by time I
watched all my children for 30 years but
what's-her-face
Erica Kane's daughter was named Kendall
Wright and she was played by and
originally played by the girl who
married Freddie Prinze jr. Sarah
Michelle Gellar yeah and she was it was
before she played it was before Buffy
the Vampire Slayer and before she got
famous so this was her first thing which
was a teenager I hated her so much I
used to see her in Soho smoking the
Cutie I don't like that little head huh
Philippe when you talk dogs I'm sorry
well yeah man in other pens you know who
you hang out with
they give us like watching the American
soap operas because man once you get
into it you're into it and and then like
I'm the the Spanish soap operas these
don't end yeah that's the thing that's I
didn't understand that about novellas
that they end after a while after a
while and then you just those characters
are dead or gone I don't want to do that
I could we continue this saga for
another 20 years I know you could
you could because like Betty La Fea that
other soap opera that has Luke and Laura
I never hospital he's here they kept
coming back yeah they were always
welcome he did he went off and did UHF
bad guys here but I used to watch when I
was living now with my baby mama we used
to watch loving at 11 o'clock yeah that
was a half hours 11:30 to 12:30 to 12
yeah another world or Days of Our Lives
these are lives I used to watch loving
things of our lives and another word
thing no no no the world I forgot which
one I wore but other mean Gail it was
Steph I know
remember patches how'd you disappear in
a store bro hatch patch he did do I like
that I want to be there for a dog I
thought it was so cool but then he ran
ever since dude that kind of didn't like
him and it was Donovan and he had to be
like the main guy in a nanny British
like down a bit and then later on Brooke
like so purpose in let the Englishman
get so into it that let be the somebody
in the episode always had an evil twin
brother somewhere somebody like right
now there's a nice Felipe's father
somewhere out of the drink who doesn't
do anything man you know so that Muriel
is by himself as a nerd but yeah but
yeah like cuz cuz I later on I think
Donovan had an evil brother they showed
up out of nowhere
yeah so we thought patch died right then
little rod like it would like to see
their finale their food shows up all
tore up at the beach the patch would be
near the I hit a whole new life bro
really yeah man so I worked out for a
long time like least a man
Lisa knows her soap opera food we were
watching movies we could watch a porn
she blame
I don't know 30 debutante the girl that
married - she's murdered - like Black
IPA
oh yeah Fergie Josh Duhamel he was a
very she was on Vegas - but TV show
Vegas with James Caan he was on that
show he was my man crush for a little
while but then he got his teeth [ __ ]
that guy I like this character soap
operas I never watched one do the wrong
whoppers bro they're all good-looking
bro I mean a mirror in a mirror Rivera
Santa Barbara I just thought that's what
like women like ladies that had kids
would watch when they would go to school
in the husband's would go to work
there's dramatic yeah but the kids end
up watching that's how I ended up
watching watching five or six years old
I was yeah I know that we're also like
there are invigorating through our
beautiful girl there is an ugly fool
even if you like - even if you the
rapist of the other soap opera you're
like you know what I could see how she
could have let him a handsome rapey
they're all handsome bro yeah didn't
Denzel Washington come out of a soap
opera George Clooney
I'm George Clooney I don't know but
Judge Judy was in a show call a bottom
seen elsewhere or something
Denzel with anything else okay and
that's a soap opera
medical drama like like it was like Oh
medical drama yeah kind of like that so
um I don't know if I'm sure Philly
Felicity felicity Grey's Anatomy oh yeah
yeah I think he died in that show oh
damn he become a ghost
an image that's always that's always
like um you know um they're always thugs
how when you're when you're like on a
show you
after showing your favorite character
dies oh he wanted food to come back with
and he come back as a black hairs goes
even watch it again dude yeah man so you
never was like soap opera with your
mouth novellas know what do you know
what's it work Roy okay the zoo coming
out to see the intro oh my god who they
paid Erik Estrada nasty money much money
to play outdoors more headers on Camino
there was a meet on show he had stay
with both of them were they're gonna be
in both Moorhead is on pepino yeah
that's the ultimate arms scanner teens
with someone to do was someone who could
get caught cheating they put you in a
meeting like that with a chick you're
messing around with and I check your
with those small head is oh baby no well
a soap opera that Erik Estrada was then
was called I'm to where may know one
road but we call it two women one penis
and that was the 90s on they paid him so
much money and you know he couldn't
speak Spanish for reconnecting Spanish
that they had to one he had to learn his
lines in Spanish but he never actually
learned how to speak Spanish like all
Hispanics yes to solve it real quick so
he's faking it I bet you years he's from
this worthy from Cali or easy solve the
East Coast
well as I guess that's funny will you
meet one nationality you start thinking
about other nationality like a pro you
Vietnamese do you know that Gavin let's
I'm attending something that's that
others a tan fan temper were so people
this weekend this Friday to light
we're in Salinas California we're at the
Fox Theater the show is sold out what oh
yeah you like 45 tickets left but if you
should I get two tickets together
they're not together okay
they're not together at all they're
separated like you get a stood in the
front and that's in the back and then
Saturday Bakersfield at Fox to you
there's some ticket left
December 14 through 17
Allison improv in Addison Texas Saturday
night sold-out show a
I'm sold out bro never happened how
broke Daisy don't if it's low level we
were there right yeah yeah they look it
sold out but shows have sold out but
never before you go
Thank You HBO people who want it also in
January I'm coming to Boulder Colorado
Portland Oregon Chicago Illinois New
York New York Palm Springs
Coachella California Tucson Arizona
check out Philippe world.com tour for
all shows and dates and ticket links
shoutouts to these fools as we go Milo
so underscore saticon oh thank you very
much big dog who wishes a podcast could
be longer for Jonas three cou listening
from the Czech Republic even though he's
Mexican Republic
check check better check yourself before
you wreck yourself
right give us some joy a cocoa bro they
miss it can be messing around over there
they'll put you in that Russian great go
move squeeze some [ __ ] hummus out you
ass and you're done I'll go over to a
new show on Amazon bro really what the
Americans know I'm still watching that
[ __ ] okay
it gets better on dude I got the first
episode that she was I'm gonna watch the
next one today oh man you gotta watch it
what's the new show you're talking about
oh man I like watching shows bad of
places that I just want us you know he
wants a travel show and you see
everything as we're all fooled before we
get to that Anthony Bourdain bro he has
a little Vangelis show right uh-huh
when he filmed his show in Los Angeles
he went to Boyle Heights and he
interviewed I'm our magic all right
and they were eating somewhere and I'm
betting it's Trejo okay
hey any of you Dom mr. cartoon and
Estevan Oriol okay right and he refused
to leave him for Boyle Heights they go
on his jog but he interviewed some guy
that he only spoke to for like maybe 10
minutes they heat up the whole show
should have been around this guy this
gave me one of the cuffs on a rampart
division
clean up Chicano bro he spoke for a
little bit bro he put heat he threw
cheese in the conversation bro we gotta
get that guy on a podcast
find out who his name and we're gonna
have him on the show but anyways they
started talking about them which I never
really knew he said to the ho that
Denzel Washington movie training day
it's all based on a cop from rampart
really a brother too
he goes I don't know he didn't he didn't
mention name but it was all based on a
real situation happened in rampart
division he was I was caught up in to
and all that she has doing
he is started talking that's awesome
dude what's up fool
have a seat sir so a new show that into
a man on Amazon is called um well so I
was travel shows right so they showed us
baton ingredien Greenland and Iceland
it's a cop show so you know how you
watch something then it turns you like
this you might like that so they told me
if you like Fargo you're gonna like this
show and I realized why they chose that
show because they based that because on
the content because Fargo it's cold as
hell right so there's no Greenland so
they showed in Iceland so the show
basically they found a dead body and
there's a big ship coming in so
everybody in that ship can't get out to
ship so the whole episode is about the
whole series about the murder and
somebody is like murdering the Orient
Express but in a ship and it's all
Iceland and it's snowy bro like all
white snow well they're investigating it
yeah man what's it called its called
trapped trapped okay
you don't mean man fine we're showed and
I wanna get into a plane I like to watch
show that nobody watching cuz I think
they're funny man
yeah anyway I need some new shows like
our guest bro poor detective in France
Bonjour my love mirabela Italian next
door were so fool please bro I've been
excited since the last weekend Ontario
when we see I've been wearing the same
sweater I got the same shirt thank you
oh man I was by your house no well there
was a fire riverbottom last week
supposedly set by homeless people that's
out but no there's no fire just mad
winds there's fire hurt my house bro
[ __ ] Thousand Oaks they named it to
arena
silly to a couple of Oaks it was a fire
bro I'm the fire bro there's people out
there are wicked I was getting bit
there's people that are telling me to
already claim false claims for fires
even though they do not have fire my
house some guy told me but I woke up in
the morning he said I looked in the
bottom of the pool and with all black
full of ashes then my live driver some
Armenian that's a failure he said my
friend you could file a claim you have a
stress on your ebook maybe get them
$7,000 for cleaning like I would do it
for like 200 bucks yeah but no Armenian
oil Armenian to Armenians my friend were
so fool we have a guest today man
I know this we're so lucky to have him
we ever have a guy with this many movie
credits and we had who America so the
monarchy Emilio Rivera okay my neighbor
owed neighbor that foo can make the rain
stop the mailman for you right here we
have tomorrow's you go
give us introducing bro with sums no
pressure proper New York accent Brooklyn
it soprano well this guy right yeah well
you guys made oh whoa
thanks a lot everybody on the breeding a
true treasure gem I hid East Coast works
on Rocky Asuna nor the tener este tipo
key una Estrella
tremendo Anor me por favor Senor si
Senor knows ladies and gentlemen Yorick
from New York City Lower East Side
Elliott over 300 movies please put your
hands together for mr. Boogie Nights
Louise Guzman were so fool
Sammy anything put the ball man thank
you for being a show well it's an
honorable they weren't a better shirt
basket that's it
well let me tell you soon Basquiat
you're [ __ ] badass man about to say
this I might have to say that sit over
okay double time
you're [ __ ] double badass thank you
babe you know I start call your show on
Saturday bro and it was like well I
thought I seen your HBO special
first of all okay but seeing you live I
said [ __ ] man this brother knock on my
door three or four in the morning he's
coming in what's up y'all we ain't gonna
stop talkin here let's go Dalli Dalli
your bad ass and it's an honor for me to
be sitting next to you oh man the honor
is mutual our jiggle yeah man yeah man
that was a great introduction bro oh
thank you very much only to you but you
are the key that you keep introduction
the king of the roaches right well so
Rosie would leave fires Dean the roaches
everybody right scattering dude the
roaches are sought a survive a nuclear
blast
that's only in little Samoa they won't
survive the fire though I don't know man
there was a house that burned down okay
this little bit there in Southgate it
burned down we used to do the roaches
right it was a little part meant
building we came back they rebuilt the
place it still had roaches survive
nuclear blast
then why do you exist and what can an
exterminator do for it no I think it's
awaited the chemicals attack Skelton
yeah like a slow ongoing process what
are you like going back and all that
this is interesting
ladies and gentleman you have to keep
your house clean no no I got that's it I
got a theory though go for I got theory
so when I talk about [ __ ] though we're
gonna talk human being right
so back in the day we get a cold for
what two or three days yes nowadays that
coast hangs down for what two three
weeks
right right am i okay am um so it's like
our immune system is shot you know
anytime they give you penicillin and
stuff like that
that's not working no more the only
thing that works is Moscow tequila we'd
kill a man that's what
liberal ever had asked my my life
yeah you walk around out yes you go
hiking you develop asthma stay indoors
for EOG go got cancer doing push-ups
that was a fake Kaufmann but I was
convinced actor please hear from Lori
side Louis side New York City and
actually this guy here he used to hustle
offer us back in the day I knew his
girlfriend worked at I used to live in
New York and I worked with Jean busket I
worked with his girlfriend well former
girlfriend Suzanne Maloof okay the
doctor she she's she's a doctor now but
she was a manager of a restaurant back
then but she's a pediatrician PR no
pediatric psychologist actually there
but she was out on the streets with him
and everything for years and she's who
is portrayed in the movie I think is it
Annabella's Jorah yes it's another woman
named faithful I can't remember but the
woman who she portrays her but yeah yeah
he was amazing
yeah so you grew up in Lower East Side
although watching this um this old movie
our man I was all far asleep at a hotel
room and this movie was 1970 the 1960s
and man there was our [ __ ] load of
[ __ ] guys in New York back then oh
yeah but the word lead to call him the
jacket gang could they to wear jacket
like they'll stay like forgers or
something or whatever kind of like the
Warriors remember the world school no
school but there was like you can even
walk at a different part that's kind of
like what la is now well you can't walk
in a different Street if you're if
you're Latino was about air somebody's
gonna hate you up and it was were you
from poo well did that bad in New York
uh it was that bad you were jacket -
yeah where's jack was your group I was
part of Elias Satan's oh and you're up
your jacket head of states in the back
with a pitchfork dancing no oh
I was watching a movie right and
everything they were getting all the
ducting is right and they were like did
it goes why it was funny another man
white man talking right they were like
it was a black-and-white or returning
that is juvenile kids do you know what
you get off the screws you know maybe
you want something productive you know I
mean we're gonna get these kids who are
paint houses you know make sure these
kids play the house it begins with an
afro he's to where his gang jacket
ya know I mean you walk colors we used
to call them colors that we didn't call
them jackets we call them colors we were
our colors and so like in my
neighborhood we had the dynamite
Brothers we have same blood the Royal
javelins the Sportsman's you know it was
something back in the days to belong to
a gang you know but I used to always
tell them dude you don't even know in
the [ __ ] block what do you Freddie
what are you protecting but it was there
was no real rumbles oh hell yeah bro
hell yeah man I mean you know I mean
they they used to be like a whole
strategy before the rumble and then we
and then we were sending the peacemaker
to meet with the other gangs peacemaker
to say okay we want to squash this or
what so if we send in the peacemaker and
he came back all [ __ ] up there was no
peace all out war on no kid I saw movie
like that with um it was know I forgot
that guy's name but he was in a movie
called wiseguy on CBS he was an actor on
wiseguy and one can't walk he was in a
movie called The Wanderers
the wandering and it was like a shitload
of gathered that movie as it got down
and I always watch a little movie I'm
gonna [ __ ] my videos would be crazy man
I'm never gonna go over there I'm gonna
get mugged first time in the Bronx I
kept watching my back you know cuz I
keep thinking about the duck East bro
let me tell you something back in the
day when you went to the Bronx and this
used to happen
I hate going to the Bronx especially
driving to the Bronx because we go we go
to somebody's family we come back let's
go it's 2:00 3:00 in the morning turn on
the [ __ ] car the car though internal
well [ __ ] you stealing a batteries
man
and then some guy what happened but but
somebody stole your battery man yo I got
one right here and he's yours and it's
my [ __ ] battery man happened to me in
Ohio first day of school they stole my
dad's battery no and then he went down
the street to buy a new battery from
like the salvage lot and they had our
back people would chain their hoods
closed people don't know about the hood
man we had to put a lock in our
batteries before the car alarms your car
had a lock in the front yeah man if you
caught overheat it may be hard to open
that lock can you find a lot of shame my
father's body was taken one time and now
who knew who took it and he knocked in
the house and he walked in there and a
fool of smoking crack and he get picked
up at Sears battery and walked out they
do BG thorny we don't have to worry
about that [ __ ] no more or that come no
lie man when I remember listening to
Tracy Morgan and he was talking about
when he got his real famous and he was
trying to move
he said that we moved that he moved out
at his house at 2:00 in the morning and
I was off park who the house who moves
at 2:00 in the morning people in New
York huh people in the hood that don't
want anybody to know where they going
I did that yeah he said they would have
followed him I did that I did that man I
came into some money am I gonna tell you
how I came into some money and all my
boys wanted me to take my father's car
and drive to Las Vegas and I said let me
think about it guys let me think about
it I think we'll get together tomorrow
bro
I got it before in the morning I went
down to the bus terminal got on the bus
slipped out of town for like a month
nobody knew where I was and I kept all
the money you ever go back to the
neighborhood and you see that you're the
people doing the same thing well well
let me tell you about that let me tell
you about that so you know when when
they got to the point that like people I
began to notice who I was and I was
making it you know one day I was walking
down pitched
and this brother yo Louie yo what's up
Papa and I'm looking at it's like oh
[ __ ] this guy and he's like calling me
inca and he comes over to Papa I you
through yeah
and there you go you're a band you got
10 bucks and I looked at him I said let
me tell you bro I got 10 bucks you ain't
[ __ ] getting it because I remember
back in the day when we used to like
choose like dudes gonna be a whole
basketball team you never [ __ ] chose
me and your basketball team so I won't
keep my $10 and Papa I'm out of here
[ __ ] that when he went Last Comic
Standing somebody hit him up to see if
they he would pay their rent
get out cuz they backed him up one time
in a fight years ago yeah oh no [ __ ] so
it's time to pay up
yeah yeah you want to take G's get the
[ __ ] out of here man a hundred for every
year
yeah man that guy he hold no gun I was
holding it all he did was backup like
who just turned behind me if something
went down he would've done something but
I ain't never doing everything wrong but
now I be honest with you though it's
like you know I go down to the
neighborhood and I still see a lot of my
friends and stuff like that and you know
I'm cool with everybody everybody's cool
with me and stuff like that but I had to
explain to some of my brothers down
there say yo man I'm not I'm not I'm not
the money tree and [ __ ] you know and so
I always take everybody out to eat you
know something like that only happens
like in the Latino and black you meanie
we're all mad don't you forget what you
came from like I always feel like owners
if Jewish people are telling signs to
abandoned you forget where you came from
to forget about your rabbi here and here
in Brooklyn
I never heard that but this is new to me
but Massapequa break bread homie I think
people who make it who are ethnic I
think these they're people of the fans
who are the same ethnicity feel like hey
you belong to us in some way you know
you you made it it's like one of us
making it but they feel a connection
like you know you got to give back you
got they that's why George Lopez is
called a sellout that's why they call
everyone
sell out who makes it to a certain point
and talk to certain people anymore I
seen people say bathtub about Paul
Rodriguez and I'm like dude you didn't
even know how much money he's donated
over his lives oh yeah that's right good
he busts those people to the lab factors
like a bunch of people from venture area
that woman was like talking to him he
felt bad for any like stuffed a bunch of
money in her pocket like he's he's
constantly helping people well you know
what I'd be honest with you I mean
that's the most important thing man the
most important gift that we have whether
we're actors comedians and stuff like
that is is being humble you know because
it's like I never forget where I come
from and if I could help I will help I
don't need to be asked to help because
you know I know what it is to ask for
help myself because I've been there I've
been in those places you know and so you
know you never forget you know and and
and and and people that do forget man
you know that this thing called Karma
what goes around comes around but you
know I don't have to deal with that and
you don't have to deal with that because
you know we're grounded with good people
we're [ __ ] crazy but you know we know
we know our roots so I work with mob
comedians from New York they they know
you well they know you like I know I
worked with some was that guy named Vega
Oh Tony
yeah no you're the comedian to become
here for New York one of them right on
John on the bus team and I show I'm
how's the buggy how's the buggin yeah
okay John Leguizamo yeah
one of the writers he I worked with him
under and they'll pass it back with it
what kind his name right now John Baker
he wrote for he Vega he wrote for our
Chris Rock he was he was showcases he
opened for Marc Anthony yeah he's a
comedian that he just stand up yeah the
Marc Anthony show I mean mark Viera
no not Mira I know my other comedian he
was oh oh he was I'm ready for Chris
Rock with Chris Rock was yeah yeah I
know I know he's Sonny Vega right
where's Johnny I got nothing
look at that man oh this is killing me
just killing me come on that's you know
laughter two go together okay
no keep talking to keep talking uh then
again from your past Osho has no Latino
comedian these three come here are good
friends like I'm from Scarface bro
they're all good but angel angel to
start you tell me the best joke ever
Joey Joey Joey Joey Joey another [ __ ]
lovely yeah Joey Joey is like real old
school [ __ ] you know but bro so so one
time when we were shooting Carlito's Way
and so all of that thing hanging out and
everybody telling jokes so there's one
brother he steps up and he goes oh you
know man I know Puerto Rican judo you
ever hear that joke
I know Mexican judo you don't know that
at night you don't know if I got a god
you don't know if I got a knife and you
stars are funny bro hilarious whatever
we're all we're in I was doing that you
know I will come with Mike Robles it was
me I remember and can look was and I was
hosting a show and we're already Chinese
food right I wasn't I wasn't even
smoking apart I wasn't even drinking it
with joy Coco Diaz Brian Joe Salazar and
some other comedians and angel Salazar
look stuff it goes pop yeah I don't know
what I'm doing hanging around with you
comedians I should be inside that comedy
color writing jokes right now that's why
he said yeah I wanna see him I'll
straighten his [ __ ] out yeah but you
know you know like the funniest [ __ ] I
ever seen in my life
have you ever you ever seen John
Leguizamo's
one-man shows I seen the one where he
dressed he does a character with a like
a woman oh man II the fanny yeah bro
Manny the fanny is by far but I saw that
show I saw I saw it live and it was the
last show and so you know he said come
see my show and so many the fanic
on the second act so I'm watching this
and and like I'm back you know a bit and
the old man who is that babe on the
stage man hey she must be warming it up
for John the second half and all sudden
I look I look at her
that's [ __ ] John oh man he did that
she is so convincing come on bro
because I remember homeboy from mumble
mouth first of all half-hour HBO special
yeah yeah yeah yeah well that was the
first time I thought that's what he did
many the fanny okay it will do a mumble
mouth man funny huh guys guys just
looking at you guys right now I don't
know how you guys would look at drag but
I'll show you bra commercial commercial
when I get there I'm like wait nobody
told me that
just a little chick right in
presentation but you didn't play the mom
an dad and a little girls little boy
okay so I'll play the whole family okay
not you the mom all right
so man look horrible you kept your beard
I kept my beard
what's up after married so how did you
get started in acting like what made you
want to be an actor or well I was led
you there I was I was I was I was a
social worker on the Lower East Side and
I never where's my welfare check
no I didn't do well for my my going in
my life working with I used to work with
young people between 17 and 21 was to
get them off the welfare roll and become
independent human beings but anyway what
happened was one day two young people
didn't show up and I went walking down
the Avenue looking for them I ran into a
friend of mine me got Pinero he wrote
this great thing called short-eyes they
made into a movie it was an
award-winning play in New York and he
said y'all ready for this TV show
they're gonna come into New York they're
gonna be looking for people and stuff
like that I went out of this SH and
three weeks later I'm caught I'm
co-starring I'm the season premiere of
Miami Vice that was like my first gig I
show up the first day you a cop no man I
was a [ __ ] drug dealer girl number
that Dino's back in
drug dealers yeah we need another you
know drug dealer playing out I was
playing a freaking Columbian big-time
drug dealin [ __ ] like that hand brother
all I wanted to get out of that hold
your coat your name oh [ __ ] that's a
good one color on his back maybe it was
Philippe oh no so anyway that was that
was that was that was like my first gig
and all I wanted to get out of it
brother was enough money to buy me a
used car you know about this so I can
drive to Orchard Beach on the weekends
and I have to take the train and then
the bus because I was the only way to
get to the beach back then so I got the
car and my best friend Eddie totaled the
[ __ ] car the next day and that's how
I started my career like Russell Peters
say [ __ ] Eddie [ __ ] Eddie you know
but my advice but I went back to work
after that you know because I don't know
anything about the acting world so I
would get like little gigs in there and
they will subsidize my salary and then I
did this great movie was the great
director Sidney lament who you know his
own right is an incredible legend and
with that Hawk Q&A Q&A with Nick Nolte
child Dutton Timothy Hutton Armand
Assante
Patrick O'Neil you know old school kind
of dudes and then a couple years at that
we did Carlito's Way and then we was off
and running about boogie nights bowie
knife came later I love your character
boogie no cuz you want to beauty it's
like I felt like I would want to be that
guy man like just put me a little in bed
you put me in the movie and everybody
back home and I know that I'm the man
yeah cuz I thought so much [ __ ] to them
I just need a little a little one to
keep the high they put you there the
bartender man hilarious man that was my
bad acting 101 which I always dream of
doing yeah cuz you know it's like the
monsters right it's like the movie in
the movie yeah so you're not supposed to
act good you supposed to act bad so when
you in acting you get to act bad that's
like yeah
yeah you know what got you Carlito's Way
what guy McCarthy throws away okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell you what I mean
it's funny so my brother-in-law and his
cousin showed up to my apartment and
like six o'clock in the morning they
were [ __ ] hanging out and knock on my
door and [ __ ] like that and they found
this that this [ __ ] beat up zipper
leather jacket I mean it was fun for
work too and they and they go and they
go yo can I get that so I wore that
jacket to the [ __ ] audition you know
I mean cause it was like Pechanga you
know down and dirty from the hood I went
in so Brian DePalma is there you know
buddy Tim I mean Martin Bregman you know
like and I'm walking into the room and I
start [ __ ] doing my line and [ __ ]
Brian DePalma starts cracking up and I'm
like good right so so you know I'm like
oh [ __ ] he laughs man man so I
got home and this is back in the day
when you got like an answering machine
that you got a [ __ ] press to your
message so I boom I got home pressed
that [ __ ] it was the casting director
set you up a Changa and I go do that
jacket away I still got that [ __ ]
jacket but it's going to a [ __ ]
Museum no but that's that's how I got
Carlito's Way for real man you know I
went in I put that jacket on you know I
wanted to exemplify well here's the deal
you know back in the day back in the day
in the neighborhood we had social clubs
you know and social clubs you go in you
drink you know there's a pool table all
the way in the back and and it's like
you go in there four or five in the
morning like when you come home from
clubbing and you come back to the
neighborhood you hit the social club for
like a little nightcap
right after hours that's where you would
see all the Pachanga hanging all the
wannabe Pechanga
you know what I mean so it was like it
wasn't a fast
stretch you know - you just you don't
make that [ __ ] up you just [ __ ] live
that [ __ ] you know how do you um for
like a lot of young I - how do you want
look at the script like what makes well
how do you like know how I'm gonna play
this [ __ ] like how I'm gonna
wear this back well how do you come over
the backstory on someone like like but
chunk on you knew but like another
backstory like you for example you were
in closed only to write what Crocodile
Dundee - Crocodile Dundee - right
Crocodile Dundee - men never no [ __ ]
research - that there was nothing that
was that was like that was like that was
like feeling lost in the [ __ ] farm in
place that's like oh [ __ ] man that's
what I mean Cassidy no we're not in
Kansas man we're like in the middle of
night
holy hell we put a bat on you huh yeah
let me tell you something but let me
tell you we went they took our asses to
Australia yeah they had a budget they
could put you next to any tree or
whatever we went to shut down a real
deal
yeah let me tell you something we went
to the outback they build an encampment
for that so like we're inside the fence
right so the first [ __ ] night the
park ranger shows up you know they make
hey mate how are you mate and and so the
guys
the first thing he tells us is he asses
the group okay if you're being chased by
a crocodile what's the best way to get
away from crocodile everybody's like oh
[ __ ] I go run [ __ ] and he goes
ok but how fast no no the house how I
just go [ __ ] like book it he goes
just so you know a crocodile can catch a
thoroughbred in a hundred yards so your
meat you're done so you say crocodile
starts chasing you [ __ ] run zigzag
because they don't they can't [ __ ]
run things this is for you papi are you
gonna give an anthem yeah
Australia's okay so [ __ ] you zigzag
back and forth so then I said okay so
like that fools neck so then so then the
[ __ ] goes
okay next things up out of the twenty
most poisonous snakes in the world
sixteen comes from Australia so stay
away from trees and bushes and don't be
on looking on the rocks okay and then
about spiders okay what about better out
of the twenty most poisonous spiders in
the world sixteen come from so I thought
yeah [ __ ] hold on that sixteen
for a real man for real back in when we
were doing that movie you got if you got
bit by a snake you're done or or a
spider it's like by the time they
connect your phone call back home it's
like they're gonna hear this but a body
like that huh well they're not even
bringing you back in the car I mean no
man it's okay now we're gonna talk about
plants yeah yeah but let me tell you
something man there was like there was
like this little lagoon like on the
other side of like they built a house
for us to stay right so yeah right in
front of the [ __ ] lagoon that's on
the other side so you are you always
sees like these logs in there don't
wanna [ __ ] logs man those were
[ __ ] cracking down man and now you
will flash your flashlight and you will
see like these little Marbley things
that was a cracker down waiting huh yeah
man so yeah I did that movie so there
was like really no planning no like okay
we were just lost we were [ __ ] lost
would you be any up original Aborigine
people yeah we met some of those guys
and what do they like like African
Americans or Native Americans they're
like they like they like the native
people of Australia but you know here's
hither is it's really sad it's really
because you know the government there
they lease their land to take uranium
because they got huge uranium deposits
right but the thing is bro and there's
not this very true story one Saturday
morning we're driving to town and
there's a brand-new car and with the
hood up and these two young Aborigines
and they can't fix so we pull over cuz
you always pull over to help people
right
that's that's what you do there and they
can't get the car started and [ __ ] and
so I look in the backseat man it was
[ __ ] full of empty beer can I mean
for you know like like there was like
four cases full of empty beer cans and
they're like [ __ ] up and it's like
10:00 in the morning so you know I do
the thing I put my finger inside the
carburetor and the car wants to start
and I tell the guy come on come on we
almost got him over and that's it let me
try it so I go into the car and I look
and the [ __ ] thing say empty and I
say y'all stupid you have no [ __ ] gas
you ain't [ __ ] going no place
so we have to drive to town and say and
because honestly they back then they
didn't pay attention to [ __ ] like that
you know so they had like a real big
problem with alcoholism just like you
know here with the Native Americans and
[ __ ] like that and but you know what man
these guys get like ten million dollars
check every year for their tribe they
built the government built housing for
them and they still want to sleep on
cardboard because I mean that's you know
that they're very primitive like that
but the beautiful thing was that they
when I first met it was Chief John that
was the name Chief John and he looked at
me and he embraced me and he called me
brother so I looked at the white
Australians I said that's right
[ __ ] that's how we roll here
you know I didn't know back then but
yeah that was my attitude but I they
took me they took me in a hike one day
and they took me into these caves and
they showed me that dream time painting
and those dream time painting for like
tens of thousands and years old so you
know it was a good experience that way
but
like I said it was also sad because know
this I went to the supermarket one time
and the chief was shopping and he has
his own shopping cart his wife had her
own shopping cart and the kids had their
own shopping cart so their kids had
nothing but junk food and candy I don't
know what she had but the chief man he
had nothing but VHS video yeah John yeah
go get higher up and then their house
now yo I'll believe he's gone whoa yeah
are you better have three or four VHS
this man because that she's gonna burn
out on you
so yeah man so you know that that was an
experience what are the aubergine it was
an actor right in the movie yeah and
he's like a famous actor enos yeah Ernie
Ernie a soccer player maybe right
I used to be a yeah yeah oh yeah I'll
tell you funny story
yeah so people like you know I'm always
like pranking people so there was a time
that people said y'all so where you from
you know oh yeah I'm part porter weekend
part have original and people people
wait you Puerto Rican an Aborigine how
the [ __ ] did that happen well you know
my father and I talk with the defense
well you know my father he was in the
Merchant Marines and he went to
Australia and he met my mom and the bush
and he went back and he met up with her
and she said hey this is your son and he
bought me back I couldn't raise me in
the bush and people funny and when they
asked Tracy Morgan who your father is
anything Ernest Borgnine which is kind
of believable you never know you never
know
you never know would you father Felipe
apology yeah no she left
he's totally people that my son he's
paid back my child support you've done
stand-up comedy I never I'm trouble I
tell you funny well III improv anytime
like like I do the show and it's like
everything is scripted right so you know
you're supposed to always follow the
script I'm always like just throwing
[ __ ] in there you know I mean I love
comedy I've been asked to do stand-up I
actually did an accidental 15 minute
routine because some somebody a friend
of mine asked me to introduce somebody
at one of his shows and I go oh [ __ ]
yeah man that takes 30 seconds and so I
came down and I saw my name and I said
15 minutes ago
you don't take 15 minutes to introduce
this dude take my thing yeah yeah so I
went out and I did a 15 minute you were
there right how was I oh man I you know
why it was like the most amazing
experience I was like nervous as [ __ ]
you know I said this is not gonna be but
man the love that I got from that
audience and see the Microsoft yeah yeah
see you New York well you know you know
what I you know how I started cuz I had
just moved here to do a show so I was
living up in glendale's up in the hills
so the the so I said oh mom I wanna say
so I'm gonna say the dear story and the
dear story was I came out one morning to
throw out the garbage and I look and
there's like a deer like standing 20
feet away from me and it's like okay
alright so I turned back to the garbage
can and open the lid and I slam it down
and I look in the [ __ ] deer still
there so we have like this unspoken
conversation that went something like
this like I well I looked at the dinner
like the deer say what the [ __ ] I'm
supposed to [ __ ] jump because you're
[ __ ] did that just knew from around
the vehicle yeah I see that [ __ ]
I could see that yeah yeah yeah and I go
no you know I'm not trying to stir [ __ ]
up instead we'll get the [ __ ] back into
that house at the table and I said bro
just chill
[ __ ] out okay you know I try to be
friendly and then on Sun for more deals
show up and they're all [ __ ] looking
at me and said why what that's right
[ __ ] this how we roll
we ain't those [ __ ] East Coast and
West Coast deer and I goddamn bow look I
gonna go back in the house and the other
girl you better [ __ ] cuz we
about to pounce on you so that was like
my dear story but both [ __ ] deer out
here ain't scared [ __ ] I ain't scared of
you they just [ __ ] look at you that
walk what these would be a Creek right
there Oh yo yo yo I'll tell you I think
I am people don't know this [ __ ] about
me I think I own the record for kicking
the most [ __ ] rats have you ever
kicked the rats
how big was your ass man alright don't
my [ __ ] was like a good three four
pounder man East Coast right here blend
oh no East Coast
oh yeah but now they got these [ __ ]
super rats have you heard about those so
that super rats that way like 20 pounds
bro documented those [ __ ] are
on steroids [ __ ] yeah man [ __ ] that you
got a camera
now you gotta walk around with a gun
they've learned to adapt doing yoga
no there's squirrels and stuff and they
like hoard their food and then they like
they're called javelinas no [ __ ] man so
you were now all the like working and
the arm that show will you play that I'm
Colombian drug dealer or narco narcos
who that shot in Colombia we shot that
in Colombia that guy with Ashley of the
richest guy huh more recent Pablo ha
yeah well here it well the deal was man
and it was creamy Chicano and mexicana
loved horses gotcha
you know he's huge you know you know
they told me the story you know the the
group yes right bro so the beginning is
no they are like the Rolling Stones of
Mexican music right right back so this
guy gotcha
we'll fly them in
so they can perform in his living room
so gosh I had like some girl that he's
trying to impress and they're like yo
say that song again and they like put us
on yon we played that song like seven
times in a row I'm paying you
[ __ ] up play it again play like
50 times 50 time bro he they were they
were get paid with money in shopping
bags like a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in cash they didn't make that
much in five shows back in those days I
remember well those things are not there
right yeah I heard that story formed by
someone else from another mix another
Tejano group in Texas that that happened
to them and we worked with him actually
we got to meet them recently at the you
met him two at tropic a Leah and their
manager is his name is Jorge and I
remember ask you no name no names
his manager is the son of the leader son
an actor I asked a bro did this ever
happen but I didn't mention gotcha I
mentioned the other guy oh yeah what's
his name from the Mexican cartel but I
Sinaloa cartel whatever his name is I
thought it was that guy so so you - so
why not chap or somebody I wore
something wrong anyways it was he was a
guy that the collie talked to in a new
knockos knockos - what do they matter
anymore but um yeah but what else you
learn about the guy well so so here's
but what I learned was that cha-cha-cha
he was you you'd be the Pablo right he
was way bigger than Pablo the only
reason everybody knew Pablo was called
Pablo wanted to be a politician so he
put himself out in public where the
other guys were like under the radar but
bro the stories that I heard he's like
let's say us for right here that were
the cartel we could be arguing right now
I said Felipe that 50 million dollars
that just came in today you gotta take
that [ __ ] cuz I can't [ __ ] find
anywhere to put the 50 money and I got
last week they will argue about
yo I can't take that [ __ ] you gotta take
that we'll do something with it so they
couldn't hide them well they couldn't
[ __ ] hide that money because it
longer that much bro 15 these guys were
making easy fit between between 40 and
60 million dollars a week all week in
cash you know and whether that money
come from the USA because like coke
yeah oh hell yeah man back in those days
hell yeah so um I mean that's some of
the [ __ ] that I learned yeah you must
only love properly - right
they owned everything bro they [ __ ]
owned everything you know Mike the guy
that I played was like really ruthless
you know he had kids uh-huh and yet kids
right I think that Chuck yeah he did he
did you know and but but the thing is
like if I'm gotcha and you and you were
to ask me oh so how'd your meeting go
with your guys and then guys it's like
that's the last question you ever gonna
ask you cannot ask that out you could
you can never ask these guys questions
you know you can just say hello go back
that's it
how's it going okay because that was
another scene were that depth that hook
they hope prostitute ask too hard that
meeting yeah that's right
cuz you don't ask because any question
at that what do you care oh yeah they
were they were like really paranoid too
you know
but but you know it bit you know it's
like it's like you also understood one
thing man that this country here had a
real [ __ ] craving for cocaine because
you gotta understand back in those days
cocaine-fueled an economy not just the
drug because I mean I remember back in
the day it's like you know it's payday
you get paid you go get a haircut you go
get an outfit you take your old lady out
to dinner so you go clubbin
now you're gonna be drinking now you're
gonna be shipping it for 8-ball
so before you got to that eight-ball you
have already spent all this money I know
this so now that was like fueling an
economy believe it or not
everybody was doing it was so popular
disco the East go polyester [ __ ] fueled
the party that's it the Jerry Lewis to
do 64 I never been to Studio 64-54 or 64
but they're so [ __ ] looking for
studio 54
buh-buh-buh I went I waited of summer 64
yeah the black out of 64 but III I went
one time maybe twice they let you in
about sir bro no I got in because my
boys would work the door but the [ __ ]
was I wasn't impressed by it at all
yeah it was you know it was a place that
if you want it to be seen you know say
[ __ ] that man I want to go dance I'm
gonna go you know pick up some girls and
[ __ ] like that
you know so we go to like our clubs you
know where our people hung out you know
2d or 54 to me with just nothing more
but cosmetic and [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
that that's not how we go crazy man I
read a book man get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah man it's a fastest book ever at
this book in one week no shame and now
man if they ever make this into a movie
man you gotta be in it it was called
random family random family it was a
book that came out in 1990 something
about our a woman who was living in the
Bronx with a Puerto Rican family and it
was like a social sociology student yeah
a lot of people there man and one of the
guys in a movie man who does this big
huge drug dealer he was about Mike
Tyson's age or the name
you mean boy George George yeah it was a
real guy yeah yeah he passed away we
yeah yeah whoo the prison he was up
though he said well everybody was
selling crack he'll burn up like like
they did they say the new jack city was
based on his heroin oh yeah because he
he focused on heroin while everybody
else focused on on crack the same thing
that American gangster Frank yeah Nicky
Nicky Barnes yes
so Lucas Frank Lucas yeah so they would
um he was young though and he became a
really big drug dealer but this he was
the boyfriend of one of the girls who
lived in the house yeah but this
journalist was so it was and I like some
of these kids were in a movie I'm not
not breaking the other one um what's the
other breaking movie that came out of
New York not breaking one breaking to
but it was in New York and they had oh
the great about breakdancing yeah they
have breakdancing and it has repeating
crash peers not cross groove before it
was true oh oh the one that Crazy Legs
yeah [ __ ] I know the movie you're
talking yo Ramone and it was row Ramone
yeah yeah yeah I know I know yeah yeah
yeah I know I'm over you talking about
yeah Run DMC that's true though before
that one of the kids man was then that
was then they mentioned me right no
family he got one of the girls pregnant
you're not talking my Cooley high no no
no Cooley high yeah okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah we're not gonna go here the
Warriors huh the movie the Warriors I
was I was a PA and the warrior yeah
believe it or not I was a PA and the
warrior you know what now when I was
looking up the words of that [ __ ]
love the warrior by the way I found out
there that that actor comedian Robert
Townsend he was one of the Furies yeah
yeah yeah no I didn't know that
how'd you get that job cuz I knew colors
because I had color those guys based on
real guys are make-believe
it was based loosely based on real guys
but not I mean well you know that was
the era that was the era dark back there
huh yeah man that was the era man you
know that well you you you know that was
the time that the South Bronx was burnt
out best I was burnt down the Lower East
Side I mean it looked like bombs have
hit these neighborhoods back then you
know so the only thing that we could do
back then is like join a gang you know
that was like our extended family you
talking about Beach Street
Street Beach Street right there that's
right to deal with the beat right but um
but yeah I mean you know now that that
was like the gang thing back then and
what with those um when you read about
the bombing like I wouldn't get all
those buildings they robbed like they
were like like someone blew him up like
a but blocks and blocks lumps of slums
man yeah well you know you know what
what happened well I'm gonna tell you
what happened what happened back then
there were a lot of [ __ ] greedy
landlords that didn't want to provide
heat to people that didn't want to fix
up [ __ ] that was broke and so they would
pay some Takato some junkie you know
here's $20 and started firing that empty
apartment up on the fifth floor to get
everybody to move out and then they in
turn would collect the insurance for
that building so it was a whole scam so
there's no Center the building was sit
there empty chose money came in and they
fix it up no no I mean they got demolish
yeah yeah I mean and and and there and
those though a lot of those abandoned
buildings were breeding ground for the
cattle to go there that were the
shooting galleries were but you know
squatters and squatters started taking
water
yeah on the low side I was part of the
squatting movement yeah you know I 95
we're squatting oh hell yeah all right
on sixth Street between a and B oh my
god that's where I lived I lived between
B and C first and then a and B
pizza with pizza delivery food
deliveries wouldn't even stop cross B
they wouldn't know they wouldn't want em
anyway
well you there when the Nuyorican poets
cafe was yeah yeah because that's that I
used to hang out in the place called
chatter which was on Avenue B and sixth
Street right off the corner and second
floor right in the corner and and then
we had a music studio downstairs
called tu casa and so oh look at that
small world
yeah I lived on sixth Street for the
first five years of living in 2001 that
was 95 through 90 through 2000 then I'm
down to Fulton Street area wow so you're
so not what you're working on clue you
were a detective and friends and now
what now
Oh black yeah I'm working out now I'm a
trauma nurse on the show called cold
black based on LA County Hospital Wow
yeah man and then one one it's amazing I
mean cuz I'll a hospital or no joke man
and no no we can go you get shot you get
shot in our lay the drive-by they follow
your wife to the hospital make sure you
died yeah yeah well you know they have
you ever here homeboy drop-off
no so LA County they they have this
thing that people would drop off
somebody that got shot and then they
press this thing and the alarm will ring
inside and they called it the homeboy
drop-off because people would drop
people off and then that way there's no
witnesses not want to come in right you
know so yeah man it was a real thing
called homeboy drop-off but um it's it's
LA County Hospital man it's an amazing
place it's where emergency medicine was
born you know that before there was a
trauma center emergency rooms that they
take you to an emergency room it could
be like a dentist
treating a stab wound because they
didn't have trauma teams back then and
that came out of LA County where
emergency medicine was born I make that
whole speech in the beginning of the
show
yeah our brother was armed he was um
in the jail ward at the general hospital
when he got shot by the cops
mm-hm that fools like he was like he was
like in a coma
with his leg handcuffed to the bed just
in case his soul tried to leave
no [ __ ] yeah he recovered though when he
woke up he didn't know why he was
chained up bro you saw that cop that was
Jada that's crazy
now I've been doing this show for three
years and you know I'm out here but you
know I'm looking to do other things you
know to do a little producing too
maybe do a little stand-up now I don't
know how much to this I'm not trying to
take your job I'll never do that you
open in this job you wake up in the
morning I wanna do comedy go do it homie
yeah man you know but uh no man and and
I'm uh I love I love helping now that
the East LA boy and girls club you know
anytime I could I could throw a little
something their way I do have you
directed or produced anything yet I did
a movie I produced a movie called Puerto
Ricans in Paris I shot that with a bunch
of my friends you know we shot in Prague
Paris in New York it was a little movie
that we did it's the one I thought those
you were detective in Paris yeah that
one yeah that one did you see that one I
stayed with a little fresh hat a little
barrette
yeah man kept you rusty that's it no no
we shot that movie we have fun doing it
man it was just a little label love
thing so I should just do a border and
easterly or the one bro but this time it
was Luis Guzman gets lost in Germany
broke I'll make it out of there [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that we have another service
Navy Marines no I looked at Satan's well
III I'm gonna tell you the truth so you
brought that up all right but I couldn't
even [ __ ] make it in the Cub Scout
okay true story
you're like me sorry puppy - true story
ready so my mom to keep me out of
trouble she would always try to get me
into these things so she go pop I'm
putting you into the Cub Scouts you know
you're gonna be fine for three [ __ ]
months for three months it's like okay
Guzman your turn what's the off okay a
cup cow promise to be loyal
respectful healthy cool and it's like
now birds for three months bro they were
I will get that test every week for
three months and I am and at the end my
mom shows up the guy says you know why
your son you know no he can't he can't I
could not remember the oath to save my
life and I got kicked out
now you remember lines all the time oh
no she producer the director director I
am the youngest Latino to ever gotten
kicked out of Catholic school did you
hear that story no tell us so bro bro so
what happened was I wasn't kidding I was
in kindergarten you know so the night
something happened and the nun hit me
with that with that [ __ ] stick
I hit her back they send me to mothers
mother superiors office I'm standing I'm
sitting in mother superious office
my mother shows up Mother Superior says
today was his last day and I'm walking
home with my mom my mom about to beat
the [ __ ] out of me but before she does
she asks me why did you hit the nun I
said cuz mommy you always told me never
to stay hit and she hit me and I hit her
back I did what you told me and I would
be honest true for she looked at me and
she still smacked me outside my head and
that was it but it was the best thing
that happened to me because look where
I'm sitting today because of that moment
who knew on the one who knew in Sevilla
two solid came in a gross in Simferopol
chili man you ever do any theater I did
theater back in the day and I did I did
this movie called I mean just play call
Henry lumper that was written by a guy
named Israel Horowitz his son was one of
the beauty boys and he's in a little
trouble right now
now the dad yeah really to be honest
with you I don't follow that [ __ ] right
you know the thing regarding because
because we're not in trouble
right okay don't say anything don't say
anything funny Pam okay harass my wife
yeah
no but check this out man so I did this
[ __ ] play and and it was fun it was
great but one night I did like something
that you're not supposed to do right I
got a little stoned before the play you
know nothing and my boy had some really
good weed and it's like when your man is
three hours before the show [ __ ] that
lets go so I figured you know wow I'm
sorry I figured like you know by Dan you
know the buzz will wear off I get to
theater I am [ __ ] buzzing I am
hyperdrive I'm sweating I'm sweating I'm
sweating
I do the play everything seems like so
Shin right at the end of the play like
the director always gave notes to people
I never got notes which is a good thing
but that night I got a note and I go oh
[ __ ] anyone open to know finally open to
no no no no forget open the note is that
your best performance yet another killer
play to let the Indian take say a little
classic yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I never
saw that one but yeah that was the only
player with it so Miami Vice hell yeah -
now - now man who knew you know but like
I said puppy-like for me the main thing
was always to stay humble and really
never forget where you come from and
always be a giving person man you know I
didn't have to do this but I wanted to I
think you cuz it was you you know
because I think like I said oh hell
[ __ ] you Felipe yeah man that's
what's so fool fool got both the year
you got the year on the streets on both
coasts that's it you know what I mean oh
yeah and you going to New York
in January my playstation theater
January 13th January 13th so yeah
hopefully I've come into New York and
check you out
stop by brother guessed by five minutes
10 minutes yes whatever you want oh [ __ ]
I will you know I will write that New
York [ __ ] up there
yeah bad or you could just host or
introduce whatever you want reduce you
are you going to do well yeah that would
be insane we're at Pechanga Jackie bro
no [ __ ] you're put on your deck and I
through that I fill up a chocolate you
had a pendant you have a jangle Jackie I
remember you from that movie bro right
and then I said you know what
but chunga wearing the same [ __ ]
jacket that Donnie Brasco is wearing and
Donnie Brasco the brown one you know the
brown yeah yeah every time I will put on
my bra dude it's like a brownish red I
guess I like to fight with my jacket
that the sleeves ripped right here from
socking people and I'm just kidding to
arresting fight with somebody but that
was my wife
every time I my wife will see me wear
that jacket you know though I'm gonna be
gone for three days I knew he had fallen
off the wagon no [ __ ] jacket with the
seen that jacket had hose and the
pockets for me looking for cables are
priceless that I lost well you used to
find [ __ ] were in pocket oh yeah there's
a picture of me with that jacket I want
to see a picture of that jacket me with
a jacket and I'm wearing like a gangster
hat and I have braids too bro every time
I braided your hair too you'd fall oh
girl so you were in a burning day
is that poppy you gotta go come in let
me braid the hair in the Smithsonian
Philippe you never heard that
perspective huh not never man oh yeah
you're enabling me papi papi papi I
should I ever see you in brave man we're
taking you down tell him where I put out
Cobras bra I look like reality fund I'm
moving set it off
Coco Oh did you ever see me in braids no
yes you were embracing that movie anger
management that's right that [ __ ]
[ __ ] hurt dude let me see that jacket
that's the beginning of the night oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's the jacket from hell
yeah man damn post that up
oh wait and here you are with an afro
wearing that jacket make it up passed
out so we're all right get for that I'm
gonna show you I'm gonna show you my
afro picture y'all bro bro
okay here we go
look out look out cause it's about to
get oh [ __ ]
I got I got it say something they'll be
gone on January 1st nah my hair will
just stick out like oh yeah
hey I cut that [ __ ] off when I fell upon
you you have that picture the pictures
lost enough oh well every time you will
see um Louise Othman I'm moving you know
oh oh yeah well I have seen that pic oh
wait I think I saw it on his page Wow
yeah your father is Aborigine I know you
have t-shirts of that right Wow bro you
know what hey you could talk brulée all
the other how many drugs was I on he had
that bad-boy comedian from Puerto Rico
it was really good but he died oh you're
the host he was a ghost oh yes well let
me tell you so let me let me tell you
story type are tales and I promise you
that we're gonna be hanging out one day
and this is gonna happen I'm letting you
now up front
yes oh no okay how many people come up
to me and say yo I love you and ghost
but what did you have to kill Patrick
Swayze now you like if I got a [ __ ] if
I got a nickel for every person that has
told me that I own [ __ ] Warner
Brothers right now and an island okay so
I have to tell people but one day I one
day I was in Detroit changing flights
and this little old lady and she comes
with it I love you and ghost and I feel
so bad I said no honey I wasn't girls
I'm sorry so she goes so what were you
in I said you ever see The Count of
Monte Cristo she oh my God my favorite
movie said I was in The Count of Monte
Cristo and she goes no you weren't and
from that day on anybody that says I
love you and goes I go
thank you right right Rick revealing
Adam to hold the Apollo yeah
man go get rolled you the rush how many
okay there you go there you go
who's that Robin Robin yeah so you know
the nice trivia question how many people
in a movie have warned the Robin outfit
three you and you in a movie and Eminem
in the video three what were they who
are they
Jerry O'Connell right I mean that's not
his name and the real bobbin and then
Burt Burt what's it Burt you young Burt
Ward
yeah I mean yeah I bought ekwa a la fimo
wearing the rabbit outfit think about
that but the Arsenal for Rican yeah yeah
Batman and Robin my mana is brewing yeah
my so Rico villians you know funniest
comedian but he told the Apollo look at
my people google him he told you God you
know that there's the roaches and Roche
well you ever hear that [ __ ] that he
does about the pigeons and Tompkins
Square Park like nodding out he invited
me to his apartment cause he lived
around the corner so he said pop I'm
gonna do my new routine for you okay and
then he liked doing them and he starts
out to 15 minutes he says what's the
matter if I you don't find this funny
it's a oh no no white people don't laugh
it's just you know we're from the hood
bro
we know the [ __ ] pigeon one brother
willing to perform in a ski Burnette
Charles Barney Charlie Barney
Oh Charlie Barnet Charlie Barnet oh hell
yeah
who's you really late Arnold I hit there
big crowds all the time
Oh like tons of crows like like like -
300 I work in Washington Square Park
everywhere you mentioned that in the
movie in the movie I'm in a movie a Kalu
- the way he said they shot him over
there and watch their part yeah but bro
I'm Charlie bunny who big right knee
warmer
he with the [ __ ] you know the D CK it
was it was it was it was just so sad
though because like you know what Rick
you know Rick that of AIDS and stuff
like that you know
and I think Charlie died you know from
from drug abuse and stuff you know but
you know there were like really these
guys were really [ __ ] that they would
have the real [ __ ] deal man
real flavor right there oh yeah man and
it was just so fat man but you know they
gave us you know for the time that they
will RAM and they gave us some really
good [ __ ] you know good you got to see
them perform live all the time
and Charlie burn in the streets all the
time bigger big time human he was one of
the first guys to do the Chinese voice
huh to the impression yeah yeah and the
comparisons too cuz a lot of like we
were talking to us Suleiman Suleiman
Carla who the comedian you saw on
Saturday the black okay yeah who's
telling us to that I'm that that I'm
Dave Chappelle Whoopi Goldberg took a
lot from Charlie Barnet style everybody
did yeah everybody did because Charlie
was so [ __ ] you know what Charlie
didn't care you know and he had that
rhythm to him and he had that life to
him and man he just put it all out there
and he was very confident on himself and
he was great that what I want man I want
people to be talking to me afterward
otherwise they'll flip it will believe
it was funny bro [ __ ] that
they said that fool had four hours of
solid material who Charlie Barnet easy
easy he would do like a lot of show like
I remember when they were making that
movie are we almost his name mom Michael
Collier Michael Collier he's a famous
street performer he's a comedian - he
was and I'm house party three he's been
in a lot of movies and he said that um
he could leave the street performer in
Venice Beach he said nah man Charlie
Burnett came in one weekend he was
filming here in our lay man he was
clearing at least he was 5 G's
performance Easy Street bro
but the problem was back in those days
our guys didn't know how to handle that
[ __ ] money because most of it when
I'm below and the other half you know
like just treating people and che you
know so mean that were that was the
problem you know but you know that was
the problem - not only for comedian then
but you know [ __ ] athletes back in
the late man when they were making all
that you know how you figured is how
does the guy sign a hundred
the million dollar contract and four
years later he's bankrupt I know man you
know I'm with a member Chris Rock did a
documentary about a famous New York
Knick player that he was like the but
the best New York Knick player but not
fool with party hard
oh yeah you talk oh hey William there
you go yeah Ray Williams and Sugar Ray
Richardson yeah they would have thought
to be big huh they work they were bored
hard you know the story gold man because
that was before random drug testing yeah
on a good one brought it down you had a
triple-double on an eight ball and you
know Shea back in the day when I release
a disease will meet the drug dealer in
the bathroom during the game yeah yeah
like that guy from Boston Celtics who
was he crossed the BRIT he walked in his
uniform waiting for his drug dealer he
was hooked yeah but I mean but that was
okay let's bring it back to the neighbor
so cool part cast Guzman Rodrigo Torres
this is partisan thank you very you know
anything else you want to add you you
watched I just want you to keep doing
your thing do a presenting man and you
know you're a class act you know and and
your funniest [ __ ] and really proud of
you really proud to be sharing the space
with you guys we're not worthy not even
but thank you for the praise oh man oh
that pops up I just do me a favor
just check out that your car battery
because I have a pen lilo I'm waiting
for me where we were locked man okay
that took me back boats who locking up
your car with a lock locking up your
yeah remember you have to put that
[ __ ] [ __ ] around your steering wheel
my dad used to close the car before he
closed the hood he will pour some plug
out bro a spark plug out for the car
won't start early turns early because
our car was stolen twice by the same
person back in the days with old cars
just go in there and it's unhook the
hood you know pop yeah I hear wheelman
over here were so cool we go
oh the repo man over here lease on the
wheel those deals Aaron over there
aren't quietly over there Roddick over
here chillin taking notes getting a cap
G we got Luis Guzman right here came in
like a soldier yeah man
please watch um go black and what um if
you I want to do something fun this
holiday weekend smoking fat blunt look
for Luis do man on IMDB and watch all
his movies
ya know it's a good read it's a good
read man over 300 movies yeah I made it
up okay
so happy you did what's up fool okay now
cracking this thank you very much
everybody
Elena later now he has to go back